the news came after a day of scant
information and repeated lines the Prime
Minister's hospital stay was just a
precaution said Downing Street Boris
Johnson himself tweeted I went into
hospital for some routine tests as I'm
still experiencing coronavirus symptoms
I'm in good spirits and keeping in touch
with my team as we work together to
fight this virus and keep everyone safe
but the reality was his condition was
worsening later on Monday doctors moved
him to the intensive care unit that's in
Thomas's Hospital in London during the
course of this afternoon the Prime
Minister's condition worsened and on the
advice of the medical team he was moved
in to a critical care unit so in light
of those circumstances their prime
minister asked me as first secretary to
deputize for him where necessary in
driving forward the government's plans
to defeat coronavirus support for the
prime minister has come from across the
British political spectrum and beyond
terribly sad news tweeted Kearse tarma
the new leader of the UK's opposition
Labour Party my thoughts are with you
and your family said that he used brexit
negotiator Michel Barnier
and from france's President Makran all
my support to Boris Johnson his family
and the British people in this difficult
moment here's a view inside one of
Britain's kovat 19 wards Bournemouth on
the south coast of England doctors and
nurses are fighting to save lives here
every day
but then also I'm a nurse so my Vitas
comforters the UK's patient deaths rose
by 439 on Monday but many more deaths
are happening outside hospitals in
London specialist teams of police fire
and health services have been set up to
respond to these we are anticipating
about 30% of the mortality in London
will be involving deaths within the
community government scientists say stay
at home measures do seem to be working
to limit hospital admissions but it's
still too soon to say how much we need a
good long time series of data on all of
these stages of infection in order to be
able to tell what the impact or the
measures that came in on the 23rd of
March are going to be we it's too early
to tell yet we need we need people to
carry on following those instructions so
that we can work out three weeks later
what actually happens in hospitals and
it's still not known when the peak of
coronavirus will be in the UK Rory
talyn's al-jazeera